2020 has really been a comedy of errors
for fox news host maria bartiromo but
yesterday
something truly magical happened she
interviewed the supposed ceo of a pork
producer and processor
the ceo supposedly named dennis organ
from smithfield foods
and it turns out that she wasn't really
interviewing dennis oregon but instead
it was an animal rights activist named
matt
johnson from the organization direct
action
everywhere and this is amazing to watch
and it's kind of like the cherry on top
in these last few days of 2020
of what has been a completely
humiliating year for maria bartoromo
brown-nosing donald trump endlessly
claiming without evidence or vetting
last week that a so-called intel source
assured her trump really did win the
2020 election
doing pathetic softball interview after
softball interview with donald trump
so anyway let's get to this interview
supposedly with pork ceo dennis organ
actually an activist named matt johnson
the topic is vaccines
for food workers another group pushing
to get the vaccine early
food workers plants across the u.s saw
major outbreaks early in the pandemic
joining me right now is the ceo of
smithfield foods dennis organ dennis
it's great to have you this morning
thanks very much for joining us can you
tell us where you are
in terms of that rash of chronovirus
cases that hit your south dakota
operation
well merry christmas maria uh thank you
so much for having me on
uh i mean it's it's certainly been been
a challenging time
um and and we have our our workers
uh that are you know in desperate need
of these vaccinations and as you
mentioned uh we're heartened to hear
that the cdc is prioritizing america's
food workers
um with this second round of
vaccinations um
it's a 30 million vaccine doses that are
going out
to essential frontline employees out of
the 87 million total
and um of course this pandemic has been
simply devastating for our industry
thousands of our um really courageous
food workers and i really do want to
emphasize
uh the the heroic efforts of these folks
um they've been getting sick for
you know really just trying to provide
for their families
um and as far as smithfield you know
what we've
we've done for our employees we've
provided them with extensive personal
protective equipment
um and offered additional um paid leave
for for sick
employees but um the steps have have
unfortunately been uh insufficient in in
many instances
um these folks have been through a lot
um frankly we we might bear some
responsibility for that but
we know that our smithfield family is is
dedicated
so it starts pretty buttoned up but then
uh uh he starts with
you know we probably bear some
responsibility for food workers catching
kovid
and it starts to slowly get wackier and
it's not clear maria bartiromo realizes
it right away
and and resilient and and the better
times uh
are ahead um and if i may add quickly
um as as as the new uh ceo and president
of smithfield
um i personally promise that uh that
we're gonna do better um
and and the first change under my
leadership is
is transparency and and at times brutal
honesty
and um and and the truth is that our
industry in addition to the outbreaks
that are happening at our plants
our industry poses a serious threat um
in in effectively
bringing on the next pandemic um
with cdc data um showing that
three or four infectious diseases come
from from animals
and the conditions inside of inside of
our farms can sometimes be petri dishes
for for new diseases hog farming also
causes immense harm to our hair and
waterways
so now he goes into bullet points about
how terrible animal agriculture
is and how it contributes to pollution
and to carbon emissions and it's
obviously not what a pork
ceo would ever say and i can't tell
but maybe maria is starting to think
something is up here
and there's more and maria seems so
eager to talk about how smithfield farms
was bought by a chinese conglomerate
that she almost seems not to notice
but then matt johnson starts bringing up
more animal-born diseases and it starts
to become almost satirical
and then he starts talking about a 500 a
500 million dollar donation
take a listen well dennis that's what i
want to ask you about that's what i want
to ask you about dennis because
smithfield
foods is the world's largest pork
producer you are in an incredible
you know an incredible spot
to have incredible impact in the united
states and across the world but
china acquired smithfield your parent
company is now based in hong kong
uh can you tell us how it works there
was a post recently
uh about the way your company operates
are the hogs raised in the united states
and then sent to china uh to get
slaughtered
and and uh and uh produced and and
packaged yeah well smithfield foods uh
is
uh uh owned by a chinese conglomerate um
and uh the the pigs are
uh they're they're slaughtered in the us
and and uh we we have an export market
which
we think is uh very necessary part of
the thriving economy to have open trade
um there is um uh
been some leveling off of demand that
we've seen in china
there was a african swine fever outbreak
that happened
um or or a round of them really um
where there was greater demand and now
there is
holding dennis i was told that in china
you know there was this african swine
flu that affected so many pigs that
there were a million pigs in the river
dead they didn't know where to where to
get rid of the pigs that were dead and
then other sources were saying well
you know you can't get sick even if the
pig was
had african swine flu if the pig was
dead so they
they cut up the meat as well how are
americans going to believe that the meat
is safe if they're going to china to get
slaughtered and packaged what kind of
processing uh securities do you have in
place
to assure americans that their pork is
safe tennis
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so we we have
extensive
uh safety protocols in place uh for our
essential frontline employees
um from from personal protective
equipment that they wear
to uh to just sanitation of of of our
equipment and our facilities
and i mean i think that uh that our
company's track record
really speaks for itself um in in that
regard but um
i mean in terms of the impact that we've
that this industry has
on on the world um we really want to
to to kind of embrace a brighter future
and
um and and with
um and with with some of the the the
impacts uh that our industry is
is having um are actually pledging
now um a half a billion dollars a year
starting in 2021
to to mitigate some of these impacts
because um what's happening
in in china um and what's happening
elsewhere
um there's a lot of concerns a lot of
people are worried about hilariously
maria bartoromo
almost knowingly is uh almost
unknowingly is indicting smithfield as
much as the fake ceo is
but his mention of pledging half a
billion dollars
500 million to fighting the very
problems his company creates
is just brilliant and then they ended up
finding out after the fact
that this was completely bogus and maria
bartoromo
uh uh found out it was a fake ceo
and she apologized we have an important
correction to make it appears we have
been
punked earlier in the program i
interviewed someone calling claiming to
be the ceo of smithfield foods dennis
oregon
we've since learned that that was not
dennis oregon but an imposter making
false claims about the company
he is someone who has absolutely no
relation to smithfield foods
we want to apologize to dennis organ
smithfield foods and to our audience
for making this mistake we will of
course be more
vigilant it is just wild and this is a
great opportunity to play a clip that
many may not know about i would be doing
you a disservice
if i didn't take this opportunity to
play a clip
of when max rice who's been a guest on
this show
max rice pretended back in 2012
to be a former obama voter so
disillusioned with obama that he was
voting mitt romney in 2012
and he pranked fox news anchor gretchen
carlson on fox news
i would argue it was better than
yesterday's smithfield prank
uh take a look and apologies for the
poor video quality
to the ronnie ryan ticket joining me now
is recent college grad max rice
he voted for president obama now he's
unemployed
and just moved out of his parents home
good morning to you max
hello miss miss usa it's an honor uh
miss america wish i could see you
but close enough america this universe
in my book in my book oh okay well well
thank you very much
um now tell me your story you believed
in uh the hope and change of president
obama and so you voted for him and
and tell me about the next three i was
huge obama supporter in 2008 i met him
in third grade
and when i was little okay
and why now are you supporting me what
was your question
why now are you supporting mitt romney
uh why am i supporting romney it's
actually a funny story
i lost a basketball game to a friend of
mine
alex during he's a huge supporter of the
show
okay so it sounds like you're not being
very serious i'm also i'm also
disappointed in the direction that obama
has taken this nation
but yeah i will be casting my ballot for
mitt romney
okay and uh true that you had to go back
and live with your parents
after you graduated from college oh yeah
after i went to college for a bit i had
to
go back and live with my parents this
summer i'm back on my own independent
i'm on national tv
i feel like i'm doing good it's an honor
okay well are you being serious about
this interview or not
yeah okay i can't see your face right
now this is so weird
all right well actually we're going to
wrap this up now because i'm not so sure
that you're actually oh we are totally
serious about that
wait wait wait wait why not
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure that
you're ready for for prime time yet
with this i'm not ready for primetime
wait i've been this is i've been
all right we're going to give max
another chance maybe when he's ready
so that's really the standard by which
all of these must be judged
and max rice back in 2012 on fox news
was an absolute classic
maria bartoromo yes humiliating herself
with the fake pork ceo
but doing it in marginally less dramatic
fashion
than uh what happened with gretchen
carlson back in 2012 but nicely done
by matt johnson a lot of the shirts you
see me wearing on youtube are actually
made by a company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better and look better the carefully
designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed collar
that won't fall down and lay flat which
i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
slash teddy the link is down below
and they'll give you 15 off your first
order if you use the coupon code pacman
at checkout